the latest figures uncovered 19 in the
uk confirm what many had predicted that
the easing of lockdown measures
would lead to a rise in the number of
infections the virus has only been
suppressed but not
eliminated from our communities the
government scientific advisory group has
said
it does not have confidence the r number
is currently below
the crucial figure of one in england
the latest estimate puts the r number
which refers to the number of people on
average
that an infected person passes the virus
onto at between 0.8
and 0.9 this is the regional breakdown
of that number in the northwest where
new restrictions have been imposed
the reproduction rate has risen from 0.7
to 1 last week
to 0.8 to 1.1 this week
as soon as people are allowed to move
and mix
even with social distancing measures in
place there is bound to be an
uptick in the number of infections
here's what that looks like
nationally it's the beginning of the
upwards curve here
that is most worrying if that continues
it means more deaths and more
transmission
in vulnerable communities in more
detailed weekly data released by public
health england
it's revealed precisely why 18 areas
now need specific government
intervention they're the top of the
watch list here
where the weekly coronavirus infection
rate is highest
per 100 000 people the positive cases
for those places
are shown here and this number needs to
go down immediately so drastic action
has to be taken and like less than a few
weeks ago it won't be the last time
places
are individually targeted with more
areas just below the threshold the
authorities
will be carefully monitoring infection
rates to keep the virus
under control